there's many ways if the government
really wants to Target somebody to ruin
their lives
you got a lot of cards to use right you
can do well let's use rape allegation
it's not hard to do there's a lot of
people that have been there that never
committed a crime but you know you kind
of have to you know prove your argument
hey let's do trafficking hey let's do
taxes hey let's do this
do you think this is going to be one of
those things that if they really want to
Target these guys they're going to keep
using their cards until they get them or
is this truly their only focus on these
two allegations that they're making
no I think you raise a really good point
and I think that's exactly what's going
on in this case I think that's why this
investigation initially started in April
They seized you know a lot of their
belongings devices things like that and
I think it's just been this a very
lengthy search for any evidence of crime
and I think as far as the actual charges
that are being investigated I think
those are going to be proven
demonstrably false I think
everything we've seen shows that the
prosecution it's it's such a stretch
they're trying to pigeonhole
um human trafficking into a set of facts
that just it doesn't fit
and
um again the rape allegation is entirely
unsupported I think the evidence which
again unfortunately at this point in the
proceedings I just can't comment on but
I think there's damning evidence uh
showing that these are not
charges that would ever be proven so I
think the fear is and also one other
fact is you know the other allegation is
of an organized criminal uh organized
crime Group which includes the two women
who were just released on house arrest
which I think again is a big
um I guess it speaks a lot as to what
the evidence is that during this
investigation now they've released the
women on house arrest the same women
that are allegedly part of this
organized criminal group so I do not
feel that they're they're ever going to
be able to prove any of the charges that
are currently being investigated I just
think they're using these this
preventative arrest to prolong their
detention in hopes of actually being
able to find evidence of crime which
they don't currently have
yeah that's going to be the interesting
part because if they do that you know
it's targeting you know it's targeting
is there anybody that if
uh for example
um you know uh uh I keep going political
because state is political and and
that's where you can do all the other
stuff it's one thing but he calls out a
lot of people that are not liking the
call-outs that he makes
so if when Trump's running and they had
their RNC who they wanted to be at the
RNC while Dana White spoke and he says
look I don't this is all I know about
the guy 20 years ago when nobody gave us
a place to go and do our first event for
UFC he said yes I'm gonna back this guy
up because Vegas said no this said and
he said yes and he helped us stay in
business okay so that gets the audience
of UFC to say man shoot if Dana's
defending Trump maybe I ought to right
hey Barack Obama hey I'm Oprah Winfrey
listen this is the guy we've been
looking for we've been looking okay boom
support you know what if Oprah says it
you know I got to kind of support this
hey the other day Oprah hey I as much as
I'm the one that found Dr Oz I'm not
going to go against Dr Oz uh for Dr Oz
I'm gonna go for fetterman I think
fetterman's better people are like wait
a minute that's your guy but you're
going there's a lot of weight in who
supports who and says what right
politically
um how much like is there any other
because ever since you know he he spoke
about his Muslim religion and videos
were posted about him going out there
and praying uh and you know how he feels
about the westernized you know
Christianity the the standards all of
that is there support from a sect or a
community that has reached out to say
Tina how can we help we would like to
get involved to help is there anything
like that taking place or is it silence
no one's saying anything they're just
kind of saying well let's see what
happens here we're going to keep our
hands off of this
there are there are many many
um efforts by people who want to help it
hasn't really come from some sort of
organized sect of you know of anything
like that but we have so many
individuals reaching out offering
support and help and you know I think
it's a little tricky in cases like this
where it is political as you said and
people are outside like the Tates are
very outspoken particularly Andrew I
think
sometimes there is you know reluctance
from people to publicly show support and
to come out when when they still do
support the individuals so I experienced
this in Jessie's case where he had a lot
of support a lot of people who had
privately message him I believe in you I
believe you but those same people felt
that in this climate they couldn't come
forward and publicly support him because
of the tremendous backlash because again
there was this false narrative and based
on the information that was put forward
by you know the one-sided leaks and
everything else people believed a
different set of facts than what the you
know actual facts were and based on that
they didn't want to come out and support
somebody who who may have done what
people were saying he did so I think
there's a lot of that in this case too
where they're certainly certainly is a
lot of private support
now who would be willing to come forward
publicly I'm not sure because I think
there is a lot of backlash
I I bet I bet there is uh uh but maybe
some need to see this and hear this to
say hey we're going to come out and
support maybe they need to hear this
message and say hey let's make a phone
call and offer what we can I don't know
what happens when they're freezing uh
freezing accounts cars taking stuff that
you know there's many ways I've
interviewed F Lee Bailey nine years ago
10 years ago and they took his license
away as well and you know F Lee Bailey
wrote one of the best books ever for
lawyers you know which one I'm talking
was like 2 000 Pages examination right
the legendary book that everybody talks
about which I haven't read because I'm
not a lawyer but I know you know which
book I'm talking about so and they took
his license that's one way where when
you're a lawyer for too long and you
represent a lot of people and then you
keep doing it and you're allowed
sometimes the way they do it is hey take
this guy's license away he can't make
money and then that's how they go broke
it's a sad situation on what they do but
in this instance you know if they're
freezing accounts if they're freezing
everything you know are are you know
maybe this this is a way and I don't
know financial situation where that are
they able to make the payments to you
you're not a cheap lawyer you're not
somebody that's 400 bucks an hour that's
a very expensive lawyer you are so if
somebody's hiring someone like you are
they able to meet their expenses that
they're you know having to pay today is
that something that they're able to do
are they Frozen right now with their
funds
so they've seized a lot of assets
um certainly not everything but they
have seized you know a great amount of
assets which is vastly disproportionate
to any sort of money that the government
would need as a result of this
investigation so it is concerning all
the assets they've taken and this you
know really comes back to
why you know they are in this prolonged
detention all of these things are being
seized that's putting a lot of pressure
um I don't know if it's in the hopes
that at some point they crack and
confess to something they didn't do but
that's not going to happen so
yeah I was watching an interview the
other day with musk where musk is like
he called out the SEC I don't know if
you've seen this clip or not he says you
know he says what he says to the SEC and
he says they called me and they said you
have to do this or else this or else
that or else this and he says I agree
but let me tell you something you know
he took a shot at SEC right afterwards
in the interview and it's a public video
going viral where it's like hey you need
to come out and say yes you did this or
you need to come on and say you did that
it'll be interesting to see like you're
saying they're not going to break that
these guys don't seem like the kind that
they're going to be break but I wonder
the government people think they're so
creative until you go into you know you
think criminals are the most creative
people let me you know people are a lot
more creative uh in the government than
they know because they see all these
cases so they know how to maneuver with
power that nobody else can you can't go
write a negative view about the
government on Yelp oh my God we gotta
know you can't do that that's only in
the free markets that we experienced
that so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast
right here
[Music]